Okay,
so okay,
so we've talked a little bit about
motivation last time or quite a bit
about motivation and what I,
I told you that I was basically teach
you,
teaching you a personality neuroscience
approach to personality and part of the
reason that I have to go into the
biology to give you is to give you the
kind of foundation that you need in
order to understand.
I would say what's essentially the
cutting edge in personality research.
You know,
I mean I know that what we're going,
what we covered last lecture and what
we're going to cover today are
relatively complicated,
but if you get them right then you're
right at the forefront of,
of,
of our ideas about brain function and
emotion and about personality.
So you get all that at the same time and
today you'll get a little bit of
learning theory thrown in as well.
So learning learning theory is basically
what used to be what's alternatively
described as behaviorism,
and I don't.
I used to teach behavior is I'm in this
class,
but I've subsumed it underneath the
biology because the old.
A lot of the old behavior
presuppositions,
although they were extremely useful,
we're not right,
which is exactly what you'd expect.
They were formulated in the 19 fifties,
um,
and it's actually the sign of the
progress of science that theories that
are 60 years old or no longer.
Right.
So,
um,
we'll also cover a little bit of
behavioral theory today too.
So,
okay,
so the hypothesis we've been working on
so far,
or we'll call it the working theory,
is that motivations set goals or more
accurately that they define as a
conceptual space within which you
perceive the world and within which you
act toward some goal and,
or to some endpoint and the endpoint in
some sense as specified by the
motivational system.
It's a hypothalamic system,
are often,
but not always,
but not only is the goal specified,
but they,
the underlying motivational systems also
tune your perception.
So you're only looking at the things
that you know to be relevant to the
pursuit of that goal.
And they also either disinhibit or
activate the behavioral schemes that you
would normally use to pursue the goal.
And sometimes those are the,
let's say,
the motor schemes,
because that would be more accurate.
When you think about behavior,
you tend to think about voluntary
behavior,
but a motivational state will disinhibit
or activate depending on the situation,
autonomic responses.
So for example,
when you,
when you were food deprived and you
start to think about food and start to
organize your behavior towards food as
an end and to perceive the world that
way,
your body also prepares for food.
And so the motivational state is an all
encompassing psychophysiological
phenomena.
It's not as simple as change behavior,
which was an early be behavioral theory
or as simple as something that's merely
setting a goal.
It's much more complicated than that.
It's useful to think about as we've
already talked about with regards to
psychodynamic theory.
It's useful to think about a motivated
state as a micro personality.
It's got one aim in mind fundamentally,
so it's not particularly sophisticated,
but it has all the other elements of a
personality.
So now,
so motivation establishes the framework
within which goals are pursued and the
goal itself.
And then roughly speaking emotions or at
least many of the emotions track
progress towards goals,
and so they kind of tell you whether
you're on the right track or not.
So that's a reasonable way of
distinguishing them,
even though there is no single
motivation system or a single emotion
system.
There's some basic motivations.
Um,
these are the sorts of things that Freud
would have associated fundamentally with
Ed.
So,
and he thought of there's this
primordial and that's exactly right
because pretty much all of these
motivational systems we share certainly
with other people also with other
mammals.
And then of course with animals that are
farther down the evolutionary chain than
mammals.
So some of these systems are
extraordinarily old.
In fact,
all of them are extraordinarily old
hunger,
consequence of food deprivation,
obviously thirst.
Obviously people are very dependent on
water.
Pain.
Pain's complicated.
There's,
there's physical pain.
And then there's,
it's mental equivalents and the mental
equivalent of pain,
our grief,
disappointment,
frustration,
roughly speaking.
And so you can,
the way you can think about that as you
know,
you saw the picture of the nervous
system that I showed you last time with
the branches going up into the brain
obviously,
but with all the branches are the roots
say going down into the body.
So we discussed the central nervous
system as a sort of all encompassing
system distributed throughout the body.
Imagine that part of that network
throughout your body is associated with
pain reception and that would be roughly
equivalent to systems registering levels
of input that are high enough to
potentially damage them.
That's where pain seeps seems to come
in.
And that different pieces of that can be
activated at different times.
So if it's psychological pain,
as I said,
grief,
frustration,
disappointment seems to fall into that
category.
A loneliness as another one.
Um,
then maybe it's primarily the cortical
circuitry for pain that's activated in.
Although people who are depressed,
for example,
or who are grieving often have somatic
pain as well.
And depression really looks like it's a
pain state.
Um,
we know loneliness is because if you
take like little chicks or little
kittens and you make them lonesome and
they'll cry which is a or,
or,
or peep if their chicks and you can stop
them from doing that by using opiates
and it's not because it stops them from
vocalizing because that would be a
possibility.
Just get them so stoned on,
you know,
morphine that they can't peep and you
think,
well,
they're now they're not lonesome
anymore.
So that's,
the experiments have been done carefully
enough to factor out the effect of the
opiates on the vocalization.
So,
and that's also led to some suspicion
that people who have have had a history
of extraordinarily painful personal
relationships might be those who are
more prone to opiate use.
And so opiates analgesics are,
they basically dampen out pain and
frustration and disappointment and grief
and loneliness.
So there's an anger and aggression
system.
It's complicated.
There's probably two of them.
One is defensive aggression,
that's probably more associated with
neuroticism technically.
The other is probably predatory
aggression.
And,
you know,
human beings are definitely predators
square meters and you know,
uh,
our closest relatives,
chimpanzees,
for example,
they're,
they're pretty good hunters.
They,
they'll,
they'll pack,
gathered together and packs and bring
down 30 lb,
call us monkeys,
and the meat is very popular among the
chimps.
And so predatory aggression seems to be
a separate circuit.
And as we'll discuss further along,
I think the predatory aggression circuit
and the maternal solicitude circuit,
because there's also a care circuit have
evolved to be at opposite ends of the
same distribution.
I think that's the agreeableness
distribution in the big five.
So in one day and there's maternal
solicitude and the other end,
there's predatory aggression and you can
imagine how those things have to inhibit
one another.
Um,
because well,
with,
with many mammals,
bears for example,
the males are so predatory that you have
to keep them away from the cubs because
they'll kill them.
Human beings,
I mean there's some aggression towards
children,
especially if the children aren't
biological relatives.
But men are pretty caring for male
mammals.
And women are actually quite predatory
for male mammals.
So thermal regulation,
your hypothalamus takes care of whether
you're hot or cold,
panic and escape,
that those are circuits that also seemed
to be associated with pain
fundamentally,
although threat can maybe trigger them
as well,
and the panic escape system doesn't
exactly seem to be the same system as
the anxiety and fear system.
Even though they sound they sound
roughly equivalent,
right?
You might think of panic as just the
extreme level of fear.
I think fear can trigger panic,
but panic seems to be a more primordial
circuit and if you're panicking,
there's an immense impetus to to escape.
So that's a difference.
Circuit affiliation to care.
We covered sexual desire,
exploration and play.
Both of those seem to be separate
circuit.
So Jaak Jaak Panksepp actually wrote a
great book called affective
neuroscience.
By the way,
if any of you are interested in like the
psychobiology of behavior and
motivation,
Jaak Panksepp book is one of the best.
We don't have a paper by him in in our
collection,
but he's a very smart guy.
He wrote this book called affective
neuroscience and it's actually given its
title and the relative complexity of
its.
Of its thoughts,
it's actually quite readable even though
it's a text is a little more personal
than your typical text might be.
And Panksepp is also very interested in
a psychodynamic and personality idea.
So he's a very broad thinker.
And so if you're interested in,
you know,
uh,
an approach to psychology that sort of
crosses the threshold from personality
into emotion in biology,
Panksepp as well as grave.
There's a great paper that you're
reading.
Panksepp's a very,
very good source.
He's a very,
he discovered the play circuit for
example.
Um,
and he also discovered that rats laugh.
So if you take a rat,
it laughs.
You can't hear it though because it
laughs ultrasonically like a bat.
But if you record the rat giggling and
then slow down the tape,
then you can tell that the rat laughs.
Rats need to play in.
Most mammals need to play in order to
socialize them.
So,
so one of the things you can think about
this when your parents do,
and this is probably especially relevant
for the man because one of the things
you might ask is what role do men play
in the socialization of children?
And one thing that men really do seem to
do with kids is to engage in rough and
tumble play,
especially once they're a little older
than to say two to five or something.
And kids love that.
They absolutely love rough and tumble
play gets them so excited that you know,
they get out of control fundamentally,
but rough and tumble play is an
excellent mode of socialization because
it teaches the child that the
distinction between the aggression and
too much aggression.
Right?
Because if you're wrestling with the
kid,
the kid has to keep their behavioral
output under a fair degree of control to
keep the game going,
to make it rough enough to be exciting
but not so rough that they get hurt or
you know,
that they stick their thumb in their
dad's I or something like that.
And you can think of that from a phd and
sense too because it's a game,
but imagine that if you're trying to
figure out how to configure yourself
around other people,
if you haven't had that rough and tumble
play,
you don't really know where the
boundaries of your body are,
you know,
and,
and you don't know how much you can take
and how much you can be stretched and
how much you can be thrown around and
when something actually hurts rather
than this frightening.
And so all of that intense sort of play
that,
um,
that boys in particular are likely to
engage it.
No,
the girls also like,
it
seems to be very useful for teaching
children about how to engage with the
world but,
and with other people in a physical way.
And that's one of the physiological for
higher order socialization.
So it's very useful.
I mean,
I've,
I've always often noted that children
who haven't had the opportunity to
engage in physical play,
they're kind of awkward.
You know,
they,
they're not,
they're not seated well in their body
and it's like they're kind of vague
physically.
Whereas the ones who've been twisted
around in Banton,
thrown up in the air and wrestled in
general,
there are a lot more conscious of their
limits and their abilities and their
body and they're also much more able to
invite other kids to play.
You can think about this with regards to
dogs.
You know if you have a dog,
you know the dog,
you can tell when the dog wants to play,
right?
What does the dog do?
Yeah.
Jumps around and it puts his rear end in
the air often and its head down.
It looks up,
which is a little bit submissive and
little bit friendly and it wags its
tail.
It might bark and it moves back and
forth and like little kids that want to
play do well.
They don't put their tails in the air
obviously,
but they,
they,
they engage in play invitation behaviors
like that,
you know,
little bit of teasing sometimes and
they're trying to get some play
initiated on.
It's also practice for later dominance.
When chimps play the males in particular
as they approach adolescence,
the play behavior because then they'll
throw sticks.
At the old chimps who were laying down
and sleeping or come up and poke them or
tease them,
and then as they become more and more
powerful and more and more adolescence
and into adulthood,
did not play,
will become full blown dominance
challenges as you don't,
no doubt noticed if you were in junior
high school because that's exactly what
happens to teachers.
Right?
The little elementary school kids,
they're kind of cute when they
misbehave.
They're sort of playful book by the time
grade eight or grade nine comes around.
The pushing on the teacher is a lot
harder and so you can see how play
shades into dominance.
Just butte,
but it is a separate circuit exploration
that's a separate circuit and one of the
things that we'll talk about today is
Swanson's elaboration of the fact that
half of the hypothalamus is
fundamentally devoted towards
exploration,
which is quite cool.
It means exploration is a really,
really,
really old system and it's sort of like
if you haven't got anything else to do
so you don't want to play.
You're not hungry,
you're not thirsty,
you're not angry.
You're not too warm or too cold,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Your default isn't sort of quiescent
sleep,
right?
You don't just
run out of batteries and lie on the
floor unless you're of course,
obviously,
unless you're very tired.
What will generally happen is if the
other fundamental motivational states
have been satiated,
then you'll engage in exploration and
some different people at different
rates.
If you're extroverted,
you'll engage in exploration in the
social environment and if you're open,
then you'll engage in exploration at a
more cognitive level,
so that would be with regards to
artistic creativity or to fiction or or
the expression of some sort of
intellectual or philosophical pursuit
and the reason that you're wired up that
way is because if you have a little
extra energy,
you might as well use that to map out
more of the environment so that when
push comes to shove somewhere down the
road,
he'll be in possession of more
information and more flexible and more
knowledgeable in your.
In your,
in your conceptual and perceptual
structures and also in your actions.
So people have a pretty strong tendency
to default to exploration,
but there's variability in that.
You can also sort of divide up these
motivations as ingestive or defensive.
That's not a bad way of looking at it.
And then there's reproductive
motivations as well.
That's unlikely to be a full map.
It kind of depends on where you put the
emotions because we know for example,
that there's a separate disgust circuit
and that doesn't seem to load with
anxiety or with pain.
It's,
it's its own biological
system and it seems to be associated
with trait conscientiousness maybe and
also with political conservatism in
orderliness.
So those things are all quite
interesting.
We all kind of clumped together and.
But whether that's an emotion or
motivations,
not exactly clear,
but
we'll talk about it a little bit more.
So there's the hypothalamus and as you
can see
it's not one thing.
Of course,
nothing at the macro level in the brain
is one thing.
Obviously it's this layered thing,
just like everything else in the world,
except even more so because the brain is
so incredibly complicated and you can
see by looking at that there's all those
little,
all the things that are colored,
they're basically hypothalamic
modules,
I guess would be a reasonable way of
putting it and you can tell they're even
at an anatomically distinct,
so obviously they're not doing exactly
the same thing.
So you might think of brain anatomy as
sort of a fixed,
what would you call something that we've
already managed quite well and we have
all the categories.
Systems down in the structure of the
brain is quite well known and that's
really not true at all.
Like the brain is truly terra incognita
and it isn't even like our naming a
rituals.
Let's say our conventions are not
necessarily appropriate for one to one
mapping of say structure onto function.
So
they're,
they're sort of anatomical,
they're markers for anatomical
convenience in some ways.
Okay,
so,
so here's a way of thinking about it.
So you have your frame which specifies
your lack.
Say I'm hungry and then a goal pops up,
which is,
well,
I should have something to eat,
and the hypothalamus is modulating
perceptual and cognitive circuits so
that you think that and so that you
start to parse up the world into a place
where a hungry person like you could
become satisfied and then the behaviors
kick in that are relevant to that
pursuit and so you can think of yourself
as popping through these sorts of frames
on a fairly sick basis throughout the
day.
You know,
obviously you get hungry,
you get thirsty,
you get tired,
and so your consciousness is being
modulated by subcortical circuitry that
is basically charged with your self
preservation and in some ways you come
along for the ride.
I mean your consciousness is mostly
there in some sense to detect deviations
from not so much expectation but from
desire,
right?
Because you lay out one of these little
maps on the world and then you want
something to happen and what your
consciousness does more or less is more
monitor and if something that you don't
want to happen happens,
then consciousness will take a look.
In some sense,
you remember that hierarchy of goals
that I showed you from motor output up
to higher order goals,
your consciousness kind of moves up and
down that thing.
If you've made an error trying to figure
out at which level of abstraction that
error should be rectified,
which is sort of what you do when you
think,
and so that process is going to kick in
whenever you're moving towards your
desired end and something that you don't
want to have happen,
happens,
right?
You usually stop that sort of an anxiety
response,
the stopping,
and then if nothing else happens,
that's too bad,
well then you'll.
You'll start to explore it in.
Animals often do that by moving around,
but people will do that just as with
equal facility just by running
simulations in their mind and trying to
calculate what went wrong.
Right?
Trying to think about it.
That's a form of exploratory behavior as
well.
That would be more associated with
trait.
Openness with intelligence.
So,
so there's how Swanson divides up the
hypothalamus see the little pink things
there on the left are part of the
defensive circuits,
and then the red things on the left are
part of the reproductive circuits and
you know,
obviously those,
the fact that those circuits exist lays
onto Darwinian theory quite nicely.
The defensive circuits obviously protect
you from dying in the reproductive
circuits,
you know,
facilitate your reproduction,
just not much of a
fairly obvious conclusion.
And so those are all located in this,
in this essential part of the brain,
the hypothalamic hypothalamus.
Now this is something that's a little
more complex,
so I'll go through it a little bit more
carefully.
So if you right,
this is where Swanson maps perfectly
onto piaget and I put this one on paper
in as a optional reading,
but if you're interested in the sorts of
things that we're covering this class,
how it's a great paper to hack your way
through,
even though it's very hard because you
learn a lot about the underlying biology
of some of these more complex clinical
and developmental theories that we've
covered.
So basically what Swanson is pointing
out is that at the lowest level,
at the highest resolution level of your
central nervous system,
your,
you have motor output circuits that are
enabling you to move and those are
communicating in large part with your
spine,
but also with lower parts of your
brainstem.
So those are fundamental movements of
the sorts that PSJ would call reflexive.
And then the locomotor pattern
generator.
I think the best way to think about this
from an analogical perspective and how
actually Alexander Luria used this
analogy.
He called behavioral patterns.
Kinetic melodies.
It's a lovely phrase,
hey,
because you know how obviously a song is
made out of notes and then the notes
combined into phrases and the phrase
this combined Santa passages and then,
well,
even more interestingly than if it's an
orchestral piece of music,
multiple instruments are playing at the
same time.
So it sort of extends right into the
social domain.
But your actions are sort of like that.
They're made out of micro routines and
then those are chained together and
those are chained together in higher
order abstractions and so on.
All the way up to the cortex and so he
swanson points out that the the motor
system has three sets of inputs,
so the cognitive system that sort of way
up that sort of level of abstraction
that's way up in the brain.
So the cognitive system is where you
know you might do a voluntary auction,
so you look at something and say,
well I'm going to pick up this piece of
paper.
And so that's top down cortical control
and then the state system input to the
motor system.
The state system is your body monitoring
what's going on inside of itself and the
autonomic nervous system is part of the
motor output system.
And so the state monitoring system takes
a careful look and the hypothalamus does
a fair bit of this.
Takes a careful look at what's going on
inside you and then activates different
parts of your digestive and you know
that the gut system fundamentally that,
that you have no conscious control over.
And then obviously their sensory system
inputs to.
So.
So those are the three main inputs into
the,
into the motor system and that acts on
the environment.
And then the motor system has this
hierarchical nature that's built from
the spine upwards and so you can think
of like the brain as a collection of
ever expanding control systems that
allow you to what learn and undertake
evermore complex motor schemes of
action.
You know,
and one of the things that people think
about human beings is that we're very
good at thinking,
right?
What we're not good at thinking like
we're crazy,
crazily adaptable in terms of our motor
output.
I mean if you watch the watch the
Olympics,
you know when you see human beings can
do things that no other animal could
even think of doing.
I mean we're completely crazy when it
comes to the sorts of things we can do
with our body.
We're good on ice,
we're good in the water.
We can ski.
People are really good at jumping.
They can climb across buildings.
People who train themselves can climb
like mad mean human beings are
unbelievably variable in terms of their
motor output.
So that's another part of our
intelligence that's not just abstract.
And so in part that's because we have
this very well developed cortical area
that enables us to chain evermore
complex patterns of behavior together
and also to develop patterns of behavior
that are sort of outside instinctual
specification.
So you imagine with an animal that has a
less complex brain,
a lot of its behavior is going to be
limited to those quads,
a instinctual patterns of behavior that
are devoted directly towards the
solution of basic biological problems.
But you know,
we can kind of solve those without too
much effort.
And then we have all the spare motor
capacity leftover and people do the
weirdest things with it,
you know,
and,
and really remarkable.
Absolutely remarkable things.
So that's pretty cool.
We're pretty cool that way.
We don't get enough credit for it,
I don't think because human beings think
about human being as an animal,
which,
you know,
people are kind of loath to do.
We are definitely the most interesting
animal.
I mean if you saw like a what a pygmy
hippopotamus skateboarding,
you'd think that was pretty remarkable,
you know,
but people,
they do those sorts of things all the
time.
And you know,
we just take it as a matter of course,
the lowest amount of motor neuron pools,
the lowest level of the locomotor
system,
it's locomotion and an action is formed
by a subset of motoneuron tools.
That's wrong motor neurons in the spinal
cord,
ventral horn that innovates the limb
muscles responsible for locomotor
behavior.
I dictated this with dragon dictate and
now then it does weird thing say so
tools,
God only knows where that came from.
So a set of motor neurons in the spinal
cord,
ventral horn.
So it's way down in the spine that
innovate the law must limb muscles
responsible for locomotor behavior.
When you start to think about the brain
as something that moves your body,
it's a lot easier to conceptualize.
The is something that's distributed
through the body and your spine is
actually quite smart.
So even though in some sense you don't
think with it,
it's capable of very complex sensory
detection and also motor mapping.
And so I'm mostly relatively automated
and relatively reflexive one level up
the existence of a spinal locomotor
pattern generator.
So this shows that the spine isn't
responsible just for the most basic of
motor outputs or sensory inputs,
it can actually generate patterns,
is demonstrated by the fact that whereas
a spinal animal displays no spontaneous
locomotor activity.
So if you sever an animal,
it's nervous system.
So it only has the spine,
it'll just lay there,
you know,
you'd think it's paralyzed,
that's what you would think.
But coordinated limb movements,
characteristic of locomotion may be
elicited when the limbs of such an
animal are placed on a moving treadmill
that's providing sematic sensory input
to the pattern generator.
And so they've done this with people who
are paraplegic.
If you take someone who's paraplegic and
so they can't obviously walk and you
hoist them up and you put them on a
treadmill and you lean them forward,
their legs will walk and that spinal
controlled.
So that's what you're doing with your
spine,
you know,
because you're not thinking when you
walk,
you're or you're not thinking about
walking and less,
you know,
less.
You're one of those people who can't
chew gum and walk at the same time.
So anyway.
So it just shows you how complex you
are,
even at the sort of the base levels of
your,
of your intelligence hierarchy,
level up,
locomotor pattern controller.
So it's controlling the
locomotor pattern generator
in contrast,
undisturbed chronic hypothalamic
animals.
Okay.
So now one of the ways people figured
out how the brain works was by
sectioning animals,
nervous systems when they alive at
different levels of complexity.
So a spinal animal is one that's
basically paralyzed.
It's brain is separated from it's spinal
cord,
but then you can separate the
hypothalamus with the intact spinal
cord.
So it's one unit from the cortex and
even from the memory systems and even
for most of the emotion systems.
And so the animal in some sense hardly
has a brain at all,
you know,
I mean the hypothalamus is,
you saw it's a little tiny thing and
everything that's on top of that can be
separated from it and the animal can
still act spontaneously.
So.
So here's an example if,
if this has been done with cat and if
you have a female cat and it's in a cage
and it's only a hypothalami animal,
it can basically manage like,
it can't learn new things very well and
it can't remember anything,
like it doesn't have episodic memory and
so,
but it can,
it can maintain its temperature,
it can eat,
it can engage in sexual activity.
It's got defensive aggression,
like most of the animal in some sense is
still there from an,
from an input output perspective.
Um,
it's also hyper exploratory,
which is quite interesting because you
wouldn't think,
well,
animal with no brain is the most
exploratory kind of animal.
Well,
it happens to be the case as long as it
has the hypothalamus.
So that shows you a how old exploration
is,
but it also kind of gives you some clue
about what the rest of the brain is
doing mean
you,
you explored new things,
we'll say.
So what that means is you have to be
able to tell the difference between
what's new and what isn't.
And so what you need to tell the
difference between what's new and what
isn't is memory and so a lot of what the
higher order parts of the brain are
doing is basically keeping track of
where you've been.
And so if you've been somewhere before
then the exploratory circuit is
basically shut off as long as everything
that you're doing there is working and
you need the whole brain basically to
shut off the hypothalamus in some sense.
That's how the thing works.
It's like you're kind of a default on
system,
you know,
your,
your motor systems are ready to go and
you're Kinda,
you're alive and you're ready to go like
a wild animal.
But the cortex dampens that down and it
does that by only allowing the
activities that are relevant to that
area.
That might be none of them to function
at any one time.
So you take off the cortex while the
animal can still do a lot of things.
But you know,
its ability to match its behavior to
novel situations and to learn new
behaviors is very,
very limited.
So it,
it becomes hyper exploratory but it
can't remember anything.
And it becomes very limited in the
flexibility of its behavior,
and so as you move farther up the
hierarchy of complexity,
then you're able to do more and more
novel and more and more complex and more
and more situation specific things.
So in the sense of providing a certain
level of endogenous activity,
which means self-generated activity.
So the hypothalamic thalamic animal will
move by itself without being stimulated.
The hypothalamic locomotor region can be
thought of as a locomotor pattern
controller,
which generates spontaneous inputs
ultimately to the spinal locomotor
pattern generator.
So this.
There's hierarchy already talked about
behavioral state inputs.
There's another picture of the nervous
system just to remind you of how it
looks.
Now it's distributed through the body.
Oh,
this is very interesting too.
I didn't learn this until I read this
paper by Swanson.
I thought,
that's so dumb.
How could I have not learned that?
Like 30 years ago,
Swanson said that.
Let's go back.
One did.
Yeah.
Raymond.
Kal was like the world's greatest
neuroanatomist.
He was the guy who really established
the field,
so did a tremendous amount of
investigation into the fine structure of
the brain.
Like a 110 years ago,
a long time ago,
and he pointed out that sensory systems
have a dual projection within the
central nervous system.
I told you guys about blind sight
already,
you know,
and the fact that your eyes map onto
different levels of the hierarchy,
say of sensory input and motor control
cajal basically outlined the circuitry
for that one branch goes directly to the
motor system.
So it's.
That's for I to output mappings.
So that's fast because there's not a lot
of thinking in between.
You might think that's bad because you
want to think,
but it's good because sometimes you know
what to do and you don't want to thank
you.
Just want to execute it as fast as you
possibly can.
So these lower orders,
simpler inputs are good for that sort of
thing.
One goes directly to the motor system
and the other goal is more or less
directly to the cerebral cortex where
sensations and perceptions are
elaborated and voluntary motor impulses
are generated.
So this sort of explains for long time
experimental psychology was dominated by
behaviorists who thought of the animal
as a stimulus response machine.
And never paid much attention to the
function of things like thought or
emotion or complex internal states and
you know,
the behaviors got an awful long way with
the idea of the animal as a sort of
simple stimulus response machine.
And that's partly because of this
hierarchy that we're describing,
you know,
because you can treat an animal as if
it's a pretty simple machine because it
has all that simple machinery in it.
It's just that on top of that simple
machinery,
there's a lot more complex machinery and
so.
But the simple machinery does a lot more
than people generally think and can do
more than people think.
And so the fact that there are these,
at least two projections,
they branch more than that,
gives you right away a sense of why the
behaviors could have been right and the
cognitive psychologists could have been
right.
And even the cycle dynamic thinkers can
be right because they're analyzing the
system at different levels of
hierarchical complexity and extracting
out slightly different,
what would you call a observations and
some of these things,
or even like the simpler systems can
have quite complex output.
So,
so one of the things that the simpler
sensory motor system does is detect
snakes because primates don't like
snakes.
In fact,
there's a woman named
Lynne Isbell wrote a nice book on
primate vision and snakes and she was
very curious about why human beings
could see so well.
And uh,
she also noticed that we're very good at
detecting
the sort of camouflage patterns that
snakes used,
especially in the lower half of our
visual field.
And she did this cross cultural survey
around the world and found out that
where there's more predatory snakes,
the primates have better vision.
So we of co evolved with snakes and
snakes gave us vision just like it says
in Genesis,
which is pretty damn funny as far as I'm
concerned.
And it was snakes in trees even so.
And fruit of course gave us color
vision.
So the whole genesis story nailed it
pretty well.
But you know,
snakes have been around long enough and
have been our enemy or say predatory
reptiles,
you know,
if you don't really want to go with a
little snake thing that are,
we've,
we've evolved.
We've evolved with them.
It's like 60 million years.
It's a very,
very long period of time.
So Darwin used to amuse himself in a
Darwinian way.
He'd go to the.
There is a zoo or a rep place that shows
reptiles,
I don't remember what they're called,
but they had one glass cage where there
was some kind of poisonous snake,
I think it was a cobra,
and Darwin would put his face right up
against the glass and the kroger would
go whack and he jumped back and he.
He did that many times because he was
curious about whether or not he could
actually bring this snake avoidance
reflex under conscious control.
And he couldn't.
Every time the snake jumped,
he'd jumped backwards.
He couldn't control it.
And so that's because all the primates
that could control it when there were
snakes biting them are dead.
So it was Darwin was the beneficiary of
the Darwinian process in that.
In that sense.
So,
so the point is your body's conserved,
all these low level fast operating
circuits and so you're a simple machine
in this sort of complex machine and an
extremely complex machine.
And then something that's so complex
that you can't even think about it as a
machine and you're all those things at
the same time.
There's Swanson's take on how the motor
system and the hypothalamus are
integrated,
so it's quite nice.
He shows that hypothalamic controller,
so that's one of the circuits that we've
been talking about that are responsible
for a basic motivated state,
get sensory input,
behavioral state input.
That's about the body and the input from
the cerebral hemispheres,
hypothetically,
that's thought or or voluntary action
plan,
something like that.
And then it has output to the motor
pattern initiator,
the generators and the motor neuron
pools and then you act lovely.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful model.
And so you can see that it maps very
nicely onto that with the sort of higher
order levels of the,
of the hierarchy of sensory motor
framing associated with cognitive
abstractions in the lowest levels
associated with those sorts of things
that you do with your spine.
And this.
I flip this upside down here because
it's I,
I've been very interested in how people
get traumatized and it's easier to think
of trauma when you flip the thing
because once you develop the higher
order abstractions,
cortically,
you know,
you say,
well,
I'm a good person,
let's say.
Then that's sort of the fact that you're
a good person or what constitutes good
starts to become a box.
The box within which all the things that
are associated with it are put.
It's one of the dangers of abstraction,
right?
And categorization.
Because if you couldn't think of
yourself as a good or bad person,
let's say you didn't have that capacity
for that level of abstraction,
which is like a binary abstraction,
right?
Good is,
you know,
one in and bad is zero.
So it's a really.
It's a really simple abstraction and so
if someone,
if you do something that a good person
wouldn't do well,
clearly you don't fit into one category
because a good person wouldn't do that.
So maybe you fit into the zero.
And that's that capacity for abstraction
is also precisely the sort of thing that
allows human beings to undermine
themselves with thought.
Because once you have that capacity for
abstraction,
you can make these ridiculous
overgeneralizations.
In fact,
they're really simple.
I'm not a good person.
I'm a horrible person.
It's like that's how a,
someone who's really depressed things
whenever anything goes wrong.
And so it's the danger,
the powerful danger of abstraction is
that you can make a terrible mistake and
overgeneralization this is partly
because,
well,
let's say a harder goal.
You're out with your girlfriend and you
flirt with someone else.
Um,
so what does that say about your
character?
Well,
she might think that puts you in the
zero category like now,
right?
You're not a good person.
It's like,
well,
it's complicated.
Is that,
is that true?
Do you belong in that zero category?
She might treat you like that for a week
or two.
I mean,
shouldn't you be taking yourself apart
completely because you've made that
error?
Or should you seek farther down the
chain of abstractions for a more
specific mistake and,
or should she help you do that?
It's like,
well,
you're not a complete zero,
you're more like a,
you know,
point one.
She could help you figure out exactly
where in your personality hierarchy you
have this fault.
So being that it's a fault,
you know,
maybe it's an indication that the
relationship is over who,
who knows.
So anyways,
I wanted to show you that because then
you can develop a sense of how this
hierarchical system can also lead to
cataclysmic overgeneralization and
that's associated with lots of different
mental illnesses,
especially depression because depressed
people generally go from a small
mistake,
a mistake,
hard to parameterize,
right,
to the highest level of abstraction say,
well,
I've made error a therefore and useless,
or therefore I bad.
It's not good.
It's too undifferentiated.
I put that in there to remind you that
all these little things
are informed
by the underlying hypothalamic circuits.
So you know,
that whole hierarchy has to be.
Imagine how it's conditioned.
That whole hierarchy of motor output,
part of it is conditioned by.
And then this is sort of like an output
or an input system that Sorenson didn't
talk about,
sort of sensory.
That whole motor sensory sensory motor
hierarchy,
sensory motor perception,
action hierarchy will say has to be
constructed so that your basic
motivational states stay satiated,
right?
Because otherwise you get thirsty enough
and you die or you get hungry enough and
you die.
It's like you have to organize your
behavior so that those basic motivations
stay fulfilled,
so each of the little ovals that make up
that hierarchy have to be organized and
laid out with that set of limitations in
mind.
But then of course there's a higher
order limitation which is more the one
that piaget talked about,
which is that not only do you have to
organize your internal hierarchies to
take care of all of your basic
motivations,
but you have to do that well.
Everyone else is doing the same thing
and so in some sense,
the hypothalamic system that's
generating the impetus for these layers
and layers of motor output also has to
do so in a social context.
Because otherwise,
you know,
you fight to the death over a stick of
bread,
which seems like a very
counterproductive thing to do.
So
I'm trying to point out to you how many
parameters those that hierarchical
organization has to meet simultaneously.
Also,
one of the implications of that is that
it's not an arbitrary system.
Again,
this is one of the problems I have with
the radical moral relativists stats.
It's like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
For you to set up your perceptual and
behavioral system,
it has to solve a whole bunch of
problems like in the really complex
problems and they're in their kind of
arbitrary in some sense like you get
hungry and you need deet.
It's arbitrary.
So what that means is you can't fill
that hierarchy with just any old thing,
you know,
not only does it have to work to keep
all the complex parts of you functioning
here and now,
but it has to keep them functioning here
and now in a way that doesn't disturb
them functioning tomorrow or the next
day or the next week or the next month.
So that's integration across time spans.
That's a killer,
right?
Because he can't just go out tonight and
drink 40 ounces of vodka and then you
know,
write the test on Thursday,
so there's probably not.
So some of you might try so,
but then you also have to organize your
behavior in the here and now with your
behavior spread across timeframes in the
presence of other people who are also
organizing their behavior across
timeframes.
It's like once you put that many
parameters on the organization of a
personality,
you can see right away that it can
hardly be arbitrary.
You know,
it's tightly constrained.
Okay,
so here's some basic emotions.
We talked about basic motivations and so
the,
the web we're going to do in a simple
ways.
We're going to divide them into two
positive emotions and negative emotions.
Okay?
And that basically gives you
extroversion and neuroticism.
So positive emotions,
they kind of fall into two classes.
The one class is the positive emotion
you feel when you,
when you run a motivational frame to its
limit.
So you're hungry,
you go have a peanut butter sandwich and
then you're no longer hungry.
Okay?
So what's the state?
How do you define the state after you've
eaten European butter sandwich and
you're no longer hungry?
Well,
you know,
you're not jumping up and down and
cheering like someone who just made a
touchdown.
Right?
So it's,
it's not that kind of positive emotion
that you see when people are
celebrating,
you know,
it's more like satisfaction and that's
actually technically what it's known as
satiation.
And so when a motivational routine runs
successfully,
what happens is it eliminates,
it eliminates the necessity for it to
exist temporarily.
So basically what happens is you run a
framework to its logical conclusion,
poof,
it disappears because it's done and you
know,
you might be satisfied about that,
but that's the next thing that happens
is another motivational framework pops
up in your,
you know,
you're in the same game and sisyphus
fundamentally.
So anyways,
it's satiation.
That is the term satiation is
technically use to describe the state of
being.
That's characteristic of the successful
execution of a motivated frame.
It's also known as consumed matory
reward,
consummation consume.
And that's associated with
unconditioned.
That's an unconditioned response.
It,
which means you don't have to learn it.
So it's a,
it's an unconditioned positive response,
so,
and that means that satiating
stimuli when delivered to a creature in
the proper motivational frame,
have the properties of unconditioned
rewards.
So you get three things there.
You know the satiation brings the motor
frame motivated frame to an end.
The satiation is also known as consumer
Tory.
Reward Conservatory reward is very
similar to what the behavior is
described as unconditioned reward,
unlearned,
so you can,
you can stack each of those things to
know on top of each other and then
you've got them.
The other kind of positive emotion is
the positive emotion that you feel when
it looks like you might get a
conservatory reward,
right?
Right.
Hope,
curiosity,
anticipation,
excitement,
enthusiasm,
all of the positive emotions that we
think of as really like happy,
happy,
usually has to do with evidence that
your pursuit of a valued conservatory
reward is going well.
Okay?
Now that that's incentive reward and the
reason it's called incentive reward is
because you're incentivized to move
forward to the reward and the moving
forward,
the impulse to move forward towards a
desired goal.
That's what your positive emotion
systems,
the dopaminergic systems that are
nestled have the roots in the
hypothalamus.
That's what they motivate you to do.
That's what positive emotion is.
Fundamentally positive emotion is
there's something good.
I'm going to go get it.
It's the I'm going to go get it.
Part that's associated with excitement
and positive emotion.
It's what do you feel?
Maybe you're an extrovert.
You want to go to a party and so you're
probably more excited about going to the
party.
Then you will be when you get there,
you know,
because it's the.
It's the apprehension of the reward.
That's with human beings because we're
such weird creatures.
So often the apprehension of the
consumer,
Terry Ward is a more powerful emotion
than the emotion that's actually felt as
a consequence of gaining the reward
itself.
And that's partly,
and this is where it gets a little more
complicated.
That's partly because we're so bloody
exploratory,
you know?
So there's things that you can learn
about that are associated with the
conservatory reward.
Those are conditioned rewards.
So an incentive reward and the
conditioned reward are in the same
category.
Although not all incentive rewards are
learned,
this is where the behaviorists went
wrong because the behaviors thought
there are consumer metairie rewards.
Those are unconditioned rewards to get a
conditioned to come.
If you condition a stimulus to an
unconditioned reward,
you get a conditioned stimulus with a
conditioned reward is a response,
but the problem with that line of
thinking is that there's actually
incentive reward circuitry.
It's not just secondary learning.
It's like incentive rewards have been
around so long,
so those are things that indicate that a
consumer story reward is coming.
They've been around so long that your
brain is developed its own circuit for
that and that's the one that produces
positive emotion and so that's also
produced by the way,
if you,
when you're taking a drug of some sort
that you really like,
that's because it's activating this
dopaminergic incentive reward system.
If you take a drug that activates
conservatory reward,
you just like lay in front of the fire
like a sleeping dog,
you know,
it's not exciting.
It's cocaine,
amphetamines,
alcohol for lots of people,
nail the incentive reward system,
and that's the dopaminergic exploratory
system that emerges out of the
hypothalamus.
And it's also the thing that learns what
to associate with consumer matory
rewards.
So I know that's a lot to take in,
but well,
it doesn't matter.
That's how it is.
So,
so the approach systems respond to ques
of consumer Tory reward.
And they also,
they also respond to a large set of um,
biologically prepared stimuli smells,
for example.
So
now you should approach good things,
but if a bad thing happens,
what should you do?
Well,
one thing you should do is stop.
Another thing you should do is get the
hell out of there.
So there's a constellation of negative
emotions that are associated with
defense and avoidance.
And we kind of ran through those
already.
Pain,
grief,
frustration,
disappointment,
and then fear,
which is sort of what you learn.
You learn that things to be feared.
Signal,
primary pain stimulus,
you know,
so a child is going to be afraid of a
needle,
especially if a child's got a needle
before.
Most children are smart enough to figure
out they should be afraid of the needle
even when they haven't had it,
but the thing is is that if you come
into contact with something that's
already caused you pain and now there's
something that only signals that that's
likely to happen when you experience
fear,
okay?
Fear is its own circuit again,
which is where the behaviors in some
sense wind a little bit wrong too
because they thought of unconditioned
punishment,
which produces pain as the primary
motivational system,
so it would be unconditioned punishment,
unconditioned reward.
Then there were things you learned about
those that produced conditioned
punishment,
conditioned reward,
okay,
but all of those have circuits,
independent circuits,
so the defense and avoidance,
negative emotions seem to be roughly
pain,
anxiety and fear.
But then there's discussed and people
have been looking at discussed a lot
lately and it doesn't load on
neuroticism.
It doesn't seem to load on neuroticism.
So it's its own circuit.
So,
okay,
so here's another one.
Other complexity that you need to
grapple with,
which is there are things that hurt that
caused you pain.
There are things that are satiating and
netter conservatory reward.
Then there are things that signal each
of those,
but there's one class of stimuli,
so to speak,
or things that you're going to encounter
that or a paradoxical,
and that's the class of things that you
don't understand.
That's novelty and novelty.
It's it's novelty itself.
That's sort of associated with what the
phenomenologists are primarily concerned
about.
The idea of the revelation of meaning,
because the revelation of meaning is
mostly associated with you encountering
something that you haven't already
understood,
right?
You explore that new information comes
out of it,
a new you comes out of it.
Okay,
so you're going from point a to point b,
what might happen,
where all things might happen that it
appeared to demonstrate that you're on
the right track,
so that makes you happy.
That's the yellow box,
positive emotion.
You know,
your,
your pathway is being facilitated.
So that's why tools are sort of in that
category.
Or you can be moving towards point b and
you get something gets in your way and
that might be something that hurts you.
That'd be.
And that would be pain or disappointment
or frustration or grief or something
that signals that you might get hurt,
which is threat that produces fear.
And so the positive emotion is moving
you towards the desired goal in the
negative emotion is protecting you.
And so if a negative things happened,
you'll stop and you'll reconfigure the
behavior that you're using or the
framework in order to get around the
obstacle and to continue.
Or if it's a bad now fobs to call you,
you might say,
well,
I have not.
I'm too tired deet and I'm too hungry to
sleep.
That happens to people,
right?
It's a conflict of motivations.
And so if you get up and you go into the
cupboard and you find out there's
nothing to eat,
you might say,
Oh,
to hell with it,
then I'll just go to sleep.
You know?
So sometimes the way you solve a problem
is by flipping the problem.
It's like we're not going to solve that
problem right now.
We'll turn to another problem some.
And that's an explorer.
That's an exploratory move.
Sometimes you within the frame,
you know you go to the cupboard,
the cupboard is bare,
but you're hungry,
so you walked down to the corner store
and you get something to eat and so that
way you have sort of stayed within the
frame and altered.
You know you've altered your behavior to
too.
You've thought up another path and
altered your behavior so that that
motivated state can run to completion.
Here's another way of looking at it.
You can be moving from point a to b and
what you predict or want is happening.
That's a good thing that keeps your mood
straight and you happy and that makes
you whoa.
That's a promise with the promises.
You're going to get what you want and
that fills you with hope.
That's positive emotion or you can have
an unpredicted outcomes when you're,
you know,
you to know you're supposed to be going
out with your friend,
you go to the door,
you knock and there's nobody there.
So it's like,
what's up with that?
And so it's,
in a sense when that happens,
there's like a hole in your framework,
you know,
because your framework was predicated on
the presence of your friend,
right?
It was a presupposition.
And so now,
and then you'll run out of behavioral
routine and one of your presuppositions
is wrong and sort of like there's a hole
in your theory and the whole you sort of
drop into it and when you drop into that
hole you get anxious because you don't
know exactly what this unexpected thing
means.
And behind that you get exploratory.
So with most people
they're going to get afraid first.
They're gonna have negative emotion
first when they're little plan is blown.
And then if nothing additionally awful
happens and if they don't drive
themselves crazy with some hypothesis
about he doesn't like me anymore.
And so no one likes me anymore.
So I'm a terrible person,
you know?
Then the x,
once they calm down a little bit,
the exploration circuit will come up and
maybe they'll walk somewhere else,
go to a bar or maybe they'll stand there
and think,
well,
you know,
this didn't work out.
So what else could I do?
And emotionally stable person,
say a non neurotic personnel,
flip to that really fast,
especially if they're extroverted and
open.
Whereas someone who's heavy,
a negative emotion,
you know the fact that their friend
wasn't there when they told him they
would be.
That might just produce a hole that they
fall into and it's so deep and painful,
they just go home and cry.
So.
So the neuroticism and the extroversion
are in some sense they vary with the
degree to which the negative emotion
system is strong or the positive emotion
system is strong and they're two
different systems.
And so you can think of them in some
sense.
You can think of them as
units of positive emotion per unit of
promise.
It's,
I mean it's a weird thing to try to
quantify or units of negative emotion
per unit of threat.
So you know,
if someone,
maybe someone.
There's a rumor going around that you're
going to lose your job.
Well how much should you worry about
that?
Well,
God,
you don't know.
So how do you decide?
Well,
you don't,
you're,
you're wiring decide.
So if you're high in negative emotion,
you're going to get all anxious and
freak out about it,
which might be the right thing to do.
Maybe you will lose your job,
and if you're emotionally stable,
you're going to think,
God,
I probably won't lose my job,
but even if I can,
even if I do,
I'm not going to worry about it.
It's innate or lot of it's innate.
So
okay,
so to recapitulate learning theory,
behaviorism,
there are unconditioned rewards.
Those are rewards you don't have to
learn.
Those are the things that bring a
motivated state to its closure,
roughly speaking,
and that makes you satisfied satiation.
That by the way,
is associated with Serotonin.
Serotonin is a satiating neurochemical,
so if your levels of Serotonin are high,
you're kind of satisfied,
which means you don't experience a lot
of positive emotion or a lot of negative
emotion.
You're just kind of satisfied.
It's a high dominance thing and it's
like all the consumer terry rewards are
there when you need them.
You don't have to worry and you don't
have to get too excited.
Conditioned rewards or incentive rewards
indicate progress towards a consumer to
consume matory reward.
They can be learned or conditioned,
but they can also be a and they're
associated with dopaminergic activation
and that's the exploration circuit that
comes out of the hypothalamus.
Half the hymen,
the hypothalamus does goal specification
and the other half does exploration and
so again,
if you're pursuing something that's an
identifiable goal and you fail,
well then you're going to back off.
That's negative emotion,
then you're going to start to explore
and that's that dopaminergic circuit.
What's associated with dopaminergic
activation,
exploration,
extroversion,
happiness,
play enthusiasm,
assertiveness,
and the positive element of novelty.
Okay,
so that makes sense.
Anybody have any questions?
I know that's a lot of information,
but I kind of designed this part of the
course so that at this point the levels
of analysis would stack up so that you
could understand them simultaneously.
So the hypothalamus sets up your frames
of motivation
running one of those two,
the two,
it's positive.
Conclusion,
that satisfying.
That's innate.
It's concise,
it's conservatory reward.
You'll work for that.
Anything that indicates that that might
happen,
that's incentive reward.
You can learn that,
but some of it's also innate,
which is where the behaviors didn't know
that because they thought of all the all
the secondary stuff,
that condition stuff has learned.
It's not all learned.
Some of it's already prepared.
You see a snake that's a threat.
You don't have to learn that.
So fire is sort of like that as well.
I'm blonde is like that.
Teeth are like that.
Staring eyes are like that.
Predatory postures are like that
loud,
loud vocalizations.
Especially if they're like low,
low in frequency,
they indicate a large animal.
All those things are things you don't
have to learn to be afraid of because
they've been so consistently dangerous
in the past that you've built up a
circuit that aren't responds
automatically to the question
extraversion then it seems like there
will at least that usually.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's complicated,
you know,
because they do play a bit of an
inhibitory rule,
but they're separate circuits,
you know,
so you can be very extroverted and very
high in negative emotion.
So.
And you can be very emotionally stable
and very low in extroversion too.
So,
but they are definitely separate things
now.
It's hard,
you know,
you can flip from laughing to crying
very rapidly,
you know,
so people are very much capable
experiencing mixed states of positive
and negative emotion.
Plus there are forms of manic depressive
disorder where people are manic and
depressed at the same time,
which I would recommend the people I
know that have had that.
They seem to think that is certainly not
fun.
So
agitation,
tremendous agitation.
You're probably sort of like that when
you're deeply confused and you're really
bothered by it because then the threads
circuits are going,
but you're also sort of wandering around
going,
oh,
what am I going to do?
That's all.
Like approach behavior approach.
Motivation isn't always positive A.
I mean most of the time it is,
but intensity measures and
controllability matters too,
so okay.
Unconditioned punishments,
fundamentally they produce pain.
They also tend to ha.
If you run a behavioral routine or a
motivated framework that results in
punishment,
you're less likely to run it again in
the future.
That's learning.
If you run a motivated frame and it
works,
you're more likely to run it in the
future.
That's learning to sew.
Unconditioned punishments decrease the
probability that you're going to run and
given motivational frame because it
failed,
right?
Do you ran out and you got hurt?
It's like,
don't do that again as part of the
purpose of memory and the pain like
emotions,
just to say it again,
our pain,
frustration,
disappointment,
grief,
sadness is in there as well,
so those are paying like states of
emotion,
conditioned punishments.
Those are things that indicate that a
punishment is likely.
Some of them you can learn.
Some of them you don't have to because
they're already built into you.
The negative emotions are dampened by
Serotonin.
That's the fundamental brain system.
Fundamentally,
it's the serotonergic system is like a
conductor of the orchestra.
It keeps everything in balance and
Gabba.
Gabba is a anxie.
Lytic makes people less anxious.
It's your brain produces it.
If you take valium or barbiturates,
they act on the Gaba system and so does
alcohol.
That's part of the reason why people
like alcohol because it dampens anxiety.
Now for some people,
alcohol or also produces dopaminergic
activation,
so they really like alcohol because it
calms them down like they're not anxious
anymore and it it also feels produces
incentive reward activation like
cocaine.
So for some people alcohol is absolutely
deadly drug.
You can probably find out if you're
susceptible to alcoholism quite
straightforwardly.
If you want to find out,
sit in a bar,
take your pulse
down,
five shots,
four shots.
If you're little,
you got to get your.
You got to get your blood alcohol level
above legal intoxication or you won't be
able to tell and then take your pulse
again 10 minutes later.
If your pulse has gone up eight beats or
more,
watch it because you're probably
producing an opiate response to alcohol.
Secondary consequences of the opiate
responses,
a dopaminergic response,
reasonable probability that you'll like
alcohol enough to find it difficult to
stop drinking.
Once you start,
some of you are probably like that,
right?
You have a few drinks.
It's like yeehaw.
That's how we do it now.
Berta.
Anyways,
so,
so part of that is killing the incentive
reward system and because it's an
approach system and it's being queued by
the alcohol,
you just continue to hit it and the
dopamine kicks only occur as your blood
alcohol level is rising,
so you have to keep nailing it,
nailing yourself with alcohol because
otherwise your blood alcohol level won't
keep rising and you won't get that nice
enthusiasm and assertiveness that goes
along with a pause.
Development of alcohol,
neuroticism,
so this is the neuroticism dimension.
There's a gender difference in
neuroticism.
Women are about half a standard
deviation,
higher negative emotion than men.
It's seems like a cross cultural
universal.
The differences more enhanced and
egalitarian states like Scandinavia,
which is exactly the opposite of what
you'd presume,
right?
If you were,
say as a radical,
can't remember the name.
If you are someone who believes that
everything occurs as a consequence of
socialization,
as you equalize the society,
the gender differences in personality
become larger rather than smaller.
So which is not what anybody expected.
But that's what happened.
So boys and girls seem to have about the
same level of negative emotion,
but as soon as puberty hits,
women become higher negative emotion
than men on average.
There's still a lot of overlap between
the genders and it never goes away again
across the life course.
Once it kicks in in puberty and the
reasons for that.
Women are smaller,
they're their upper bodies are weaker,
so they're more physical.
They're there at a physical
disadvantage.
If they're in a dominance dispute,
they're sexually vulnerable,
plus they have to take care of infants.
So I think those four things are
probably enough to tilt the nervous
system of women more towards negative
negative emotion.
I've often thought maybe that women's
named emotional systems,
the negative ones in particular,
are actually not tuned to the woman.
I think there are tuned to the woman
infant combination.
So it'd be good if you think about it
from an.
If you think about it for baited,
it almost has to be that way because an
infant has to be carried around for like
a year and a half.
And so at that point when you have an
incident and maybe you're going to have
10,
you know,
you guys won't,
but in the evolutionary past,
that would have been the case,
you'd have an infant for much of your
life.
And then you'd be a grandmother and have
an incident.
It's like,
why wouldn't your nervous system be
tuned at puberty for the two of you
instead of one of you?
So how will,
how could it be any other way?
Anyways?
So you've got your hypothalamus.
And then on top of that you've got some
circuits that deal with memory and
emotion.
So I'm going to run you through the
hippocampus and the Amygdala relatively
quickly.
So this is a theory that was basically
put together by Sokolov was Russian
neuropsychologist back in 1962.
But it's a variant of a theory that
Norbert Wiener developed back in the
forties.
So here's the idea.
You wander through the world and you,
if you're in a place that you know
your memory systems,
the hippa campus looks inside your
memory systems to see what it is that
you want to have happen based on your
understanding of the world.
Okay,
so
you're in a motivated state,
but you have certain expectations that
makes sense within that state,
so the hippocampus is watching what you
think is going to happen,
but remember,
that's motivated.
It's not just expectation and then the
hippocampus is also looking at the
world.
Now it's looking at it interpretation of
the world because you can't help but
interpret the world,
but fundamentally the hippocampus is
looking inside you and outside you and
then it seeing if what's happening
inside and what's happening outside are
the same,
which means you know what you're doing
and you know where you are and if
they're the same.
So if it detects a match,
then the hippocampus,
the inhibits the Amygdala and the
hypothalamus.
Roughly speaking.
Now what it actually seems to do,
there's a little circuit in your brain
stem called the reticular activating
circuit and it's the thing that turns
your brain on at night.
If you're sleeping and you hear a noise
that you shouldn't hear,
it's like bang.
You're awake.
It's the reticular activating system way
down in your brainstem,
puts your cortex into a high arousal
state and Poof,
you're conscious.
Now the hippocampus tells the reticular
activating system to basically remain
calm as well as as long as what you're
expecting and desiring and what's
happening are the same thing.
So it's sort of like it's saying,
I know you could jump up and freak out
and run about,
but you don't have to right now because
everything is going according to plan.
But as soon as there's a deviation,
that's an normally say.
Then the hippocampus says,
Whoa,
something's wrong here.
And it inhibits the reticular activating
system that turns on your emotions,
especially your negative emotion,
but it primes your positive emotion and
it prime some of the hypothalamic
circuits to or disinhibit stuff.
Because one way of solving the fact that
something isn't going well is to switch
to something else,
so it's sort of like as a bunch of
circuits on underneath you,
but they're being held back like race
horses and race horse and then something
that you don't expect happens in the
gates come up a little bit because then
you're prepared.
Now a lot of that's negative emotion.
Oh,
you don't know where you are,
but a lot,
a lot of the rest of it is be prepared
to do whatever the hell you might need
to do next.
And so,
uh,
normally the hippocampus detects it.
Normally.
That's something unexpected.
And then a disinhibitor to your lower
circuitry and it gets you ready to go.
Now the problem is
how worried should you be when something
that you don't expect happens?
An answer to that is you don't know
that's a big problem with life because
now something went wrong.
Here's the possibilities.
You're not looking at the world,
right?
So it's actually a perceptual problem,
Like gray,
for example,
believes that you just see the world
just like it is because he's sort of a
behaviorist.
It's full of stimuli.
You don't have to interpret them.
That's wrong.
You have to interpret them.
So if something goes wrong,
it might be that you're looking at
things wrong.
Your perceptual systems are out,
it's unlikely,
but sometimes that's the case,
but forget that.
Let's say that you're looking at the
world correctly and you know your
inferences about what went wrong,
what went wrong isn't the consequence of
you misperceiving.
It's a consequence of some stupid
problem with your stupid plan.
The problem is you don't know where the
error is located and that's why I think
there's temperament.
Sometimes if something unexpected
happens,
you should really freak out.
Other times you should ignore it,
but you can't tell which of those is
true right away.
So what happens is there's a
distribution with a little thing
happens.
Some people really get upset about it
and other people hardly care at all.
And sometimes the people who get really
upset about it or write and sometimes
the people who don't care at all our
right.
And that's why there's variability in
neuroticism.
Okay?
Now what you do when you're exploring is
you start to decompose your plan,
right?
If you're,
if you,
if you can manage it,
if you're not.
So like grip my anxiety that you're
paralyzed.
Then you go into your plan and you
think,
well,
am I a complete loser?
Or is it some micro thing that's gone
wrong?
And then you can start to decompose it
and reconstruct your plant.
Okay?
So yeah,
the other,
the other thing that this little diagram
helps you understand.
It's like,
look,
what happens is when you're laying out a
plan,
a motivated plan,
and the hole appears in it,
you have to figure out why you fell in
the hole.
And then what you have to do is you have
to take that motivated plan that's kind
of running on automatic and you have to
remember what it's made out of.
And so what opens up underneath you when
you've made a mistake is the complexity
of the plant.
And then also potentially the complexity
of the world on the off chance that
you've misperceived it,
right?
You're just,
someone might say you're not
understanding me properly,
you know,
maybe there's something wrong with you
that's interfering with the perception
and then you have to do this massive
search to try to figure out where there
are lies.
Now,
part of the reason I believe that people
stick to their beliefs so hard is
because people don't like it when the
hole appears in one of their big
abstractions,
right?
So they've got these high order
representations of the world that are
shorthand ways of representing
something.
They're sort of like axioms of faith.
And if they,
if a hole appears in one of the axioms
of faith,
then all this complexity comes rushing
up and it's overwhelming.
And so people hate it when you undermine
one of their high order abstractions.
And so I think I told you this before,
don't do that in relationships,
right?
It's best not to do it to yourself as
well.
I'll start with this.
These are Medusa's and what happens when
you see the Medusa?
Okay?
So what,
what might that mean?
You Bet it's a prey response and so
that's sort of,
that's the sort of thing that occurs
when
you're moving towards your goal in your
frame and the bottom drops out.
It's like,
oh,
what's there?
You don't know.
So what's the logical first response?
Well,
if you're high in neuroticism,
it's going to be this,
you know,
freeze,
and then,
and only then if nothing else terrible
happens to you,
you'll start to relax a bit and then
maybe you'll start to investigate the
structure of your plan and maybe you'll
start to investigate the structure of
the world.
And then from a constructivist
perspective,
say,
once you start to do that,
you gather information from the world
and then you remake your plan and you
remake your conception of the world and
then you could move on.
So you do that under the guidance of the
positive and the negative emotions.
Okay,
that's good.
We'll see you Tuesday.